no one else in my family was was a
musician but there was my parents loved
music my grandparents loved music it was
it was always around a little bit in my
Fit you know we had a record player and
but I think just growing up at during
that time in the in the 50s it just as
rock and roll was starting to happen and
and I just sort of followed along with
whatever was popular at the time and I
think very very early on I was I think I
was about four years old or five years
old when we first got a television and I
would watch The Mickey Mouse Club in the
afternoon and the leader of the
Mouseketeers was this guy named Jimmy
and he would play a guitar and there was
something I just thought that was really
cool and I may at that time I made
myself up like a pretend guitar out of a
piece of cardboard and rubber bands and
somehow I just stuck with that my whole
life
well in when I was in fourth grade they
would come around in in the public
schools and ask if anyone wanted to play
an instrument and at that time my father
thought clarinet would be a good
instrument so I I started in the in the
school music program playing clarinet
and then I I got into this marching band
and really with a looking back on it
this fantastic teacher that led the
marching band and I also studied
privately with him you know he's very
strict sort of almost military kind of
process I went through you know I had to
practice every day and tap my foot in
the right place and you know at the time
it was kind of harsh almost I mean I
remember one time I was even crying at
the end of one of the lessons because I
couldn't do what he wanted me to do but
he just kept on me and somehow I look
back at that as being just so much of
the basis for what I do came from that
like a friend of mine across the street
had a guitar of actually a bunch of it
just there was guitar there were guitars
around at my friend's houses and stuff
and there was a friend of mine that
lived across the street that was a
little bit older than me that was I
really looked up to this guy he was kind
of my hero from when I was maybe 5 years
old he was you know I'd be in
kindergarten and he'd be in 2nd grade
and so anyway he was the first one to
get a real guitar and I room and then he
started playing in a band and I would go
sneaking around his house and looking in
his window while they were practicing
and I just thought it was so cool and so
it was just sort of a gret then I get to
play his guitar maybe a little bit or
another friend had a guitar and I'd sort
of mess around with it and gradually I
got I must have been maybe 12 or 13 my
parents got me a just a $20 cheap guitar
for Christmas and I guess the point that
I think where it really began was I was
I think I was 14 and I saved up money
and bought an electric guitar I remember
the day I told my mother I wanted to be
a see all the this stuff in the 50s it's
like hot rods and surfing and even
though I lived in Colorado I would buy
surf magazines and dinosaurs and outer
space and and I really was into like hot
rods and I wanted to be a racecar driver
and I used to buy I had like a lawnmower
engine that I would take apart and I had
big plans to make some sort of racing
car and then one day I thought man I
think I think I want to get a guitar
instead of
having this racing car and and I
remember I remember really clearly one
day coming home after school when I had
made this decision and told my mother I
remember seeing her in the alleyway
behind our house and I said mommy I
decided I don't want to be a race car
driver I want to get an electric guitar
and she was like oh this is wonderful
she was so she was so excited and
relieved that I didn't want to be a race
car driver so anyway then I saved up my
money and I got an electric guitar and
at that time as soon as you had if you
owned the instrument then you were
automatically in a band you didn't
really have to play you just you my
friend got an electric guitar and then
within a couple weeks we were playing at
parties on weekends you know it it just
it was and that's been my it's still
kind of like that that's my social the
music has been my whole social life
really